كان رد فعل الرئيس بايدن
عاطفيًا حقًا بعد نشر الفيديو، حيث
أصدر بيانًا مطولًا بعد حوالي 30
دقيقة من بثه على الهواء مباشرة، وأريد أن
أقرأ لكم سطرًا منه لأنها
لغة قوية حقًا
قالها الرئيس مثل كثيرين، لقد كنت
غاضبًا و  من المؤلم للغاية رؤية مقطع
الفيديو المروع للضرب الذي
أدى إلى وفاة تيري نيكولز، وهو
تذكير مؤلم آخر
بالخوف العميق والصدمة والألم
والإرهاق الذي
يعاني منه الأمريكيون السود والملونون كل يوم الآن
بعد السطر الأخير حول الإرهاق
الذي  خط عميق من الرئيس
بايدن يعترف حقًا بطريقة ما
بالإفراط في الشرطة الذي يواجهه الكثير من
الأشخاص السود والملونين في ممفيس
باستمرار في بعض الأحيان على
أساس يومي الآن، وقد قال البيت الأبيض
للصحفيين طوال اليوم إن
الرئيس أو لا أحد  في البيت الأبيض
شاهدوا الفيديو مسبقًا
بحلول الساعة السابعة مساءً، ومن الواضح أنه قد تغير ولكن
ما كانوا يفعلونه هو محاولة القيام
بأشياء ذات معنى لإظهار أن هذه
القضية كانت في قمة
اهتمامات الرئيس بايدن والآن بعد أن
تضمنت أيضًا مكالمة هاتفية  الذي قدمه
لعائلة تيري نيكولز وخلال
النهار حصلنا على القليل من القدرة على
رؤية ذلك لأن مراسل واشنطن بوست
كان بالفعل في الغرفة
وشارك بعضًا منه عبر الإنترنت ولكن أعتقد أن
الشيء المثير للاهتمام حقًا في هذا
الفيديو هو أننا  "سنلعب خلال
ثانية واحدة فقط هي حقيقة أنه في كثير من الأحيان يقوم
الرئيس بايدن بمواساة العائلات التي نسمعهم
يقولون إنه تحدث عن
الصدمة التي تعرض لها بسبب وفاة زوجته الأولى وابنته الرضيعة
طوال تلك السنوات الماضية ولكن
هنا في الواقع يمكننا أن نرى  يجب
الاستماع
إلى تعليقاتك اليوم، نحن نتحرك
لا أعرف كيف فعلت ذلك أو كيف فعلت رودني،
أعرف والدًا متقاعدًا،
نعم سيدي،
نتيجة الحرب في العراق
كل عام، وفقدت ابنتي بشيك حاول
لقتل زوجتي وابنتي
وأنا لا أعرف كيف أجلس هناك لم أفعل
لم يكن لدي الشجاعة لفعل
ما فعلته